ANKUR KOTWAL: Today we're going
to be talking about how
to make Android apps beautiful,
and we're going to
start off by looking at an app
that hasn't had much love.
This is actually the first
in a multi-part series of
DevBytes, and today's episode
is going to focus on
modernizing, just doing some
very basic modernization
techniques with your app.
So, let's switch to the phone,
and let's look at our app.
Now, the first thing I want
to actually point
out is the app icon.
The app icon is the identity
of your app.
It's the identity of your app
not only on the user's device,
but also on the Play Store, so
making this piece of identity
stand out and look polished
is really important.
This app does not qualify of
having done a good job.
So we've now launched the app,
and you'll see it's very
basic, and a common pattern
that we normally see.
It's a list view.
We have some thumbnails on the
left hand side, and some text
on the right.
And straight away, we see that
this app is actually
an old style app.
It uses a title bar at the
top, It has a legacy menu
button at the bottom, which
shouldn't be there on a device
with virtual navigation
buttons.
The images are all
inconsistently sized from each
list item to list item.
And when we go into the details,
again, we've got a
bad title bar, but all the text
is jutted up all the way
to the edges.
So, let's look at what we do to
fix this as a first step.
What we're going to do before we
switch to code, let's have
a look at what the target's
going to be.
This is our first stage that
we're going to get to, which
is an action bar.
We've got action items, we've
got an overflow menu as well.
And we're doing some
notifications.
So, getting back to that, let's
now look at what we've
started with.
Let's look at some code.
And what we have here is
actually the manifest file.
We've got a minimum
SDK version set to
10, which is great.
We're targeting users from
Gingerbread and up.
But our target SDK version is
also set to API level 10.
This should always be set to the
most recent version of the
Android SDK, which in
this case is API 17.
So, the first change we'll
make is to make that 17.
This will automatically get
rid of the menu button on
devices that have virtual
navigation buttons.
The other thing we want to do is
actually change the style.
We're using the theme.light
style.
So what we're going to do
instead is use our own style
that is also a backwards
compatible.
So our manifest file is actually
going to change into
something like this, where we've
got API 17 here, and
we've got our own app theme.
The way we're going to define
this app theme is by having a
styles.xml in our values
directory, which just extends
theme.light.
This is our base theme.
What we're then going to do
is we're going to have a
styles.xml from v11.
API 11 to 13 will get theme
HollowLight, and API 14 and
upwards will get the
HollowLight with
a dark action bar.
So once we've done this, we're
going to get a nice, styled
action bar there.
We're going to get rid
of the menu button.
But what we might also want to
do is brand our action bar to
be more consistent with the
stylings of our organization
or service that we provide.
Switching to the slides now,
what we actually want to do is
take our action bar the way it
is now and make it orange,
basically, and change the icon
as well, again, to be
consistent with our brand.
The way we're actually going to
do that is use this third
party tool, called the Android
Action Bar Style Generator,
developed by Jeff
Gilfelt from the
Android Developer Community.
Great utility where you can go
and specify various attributes
about how you want your action
bar to be presented, and then
what it does is provide you with
a zip file that you can
just extract over your project,
and you're done.
So, that wraps up part one.
I just want to show you how
far we've gotten in this
checkpoint.
We've gotten from something that
obviously looked old to
something that looks a
lot more modern now.